up you made clear that it was your
chancellor who made the decision in the
first place about scrapping the top rate
of tax
Wally would you in future leave big
decisions to him again when he got such
an important early decision right
but what we've done is we have listened
to what people said on this issue it
wasn't a core part of our growth plan
what our growth plan is focused on is
helping people with energy bills getting
business moving and we're here at this
fantastic new development in Birmingham
creating jobs for the future that's what
the plan is about it was becoming a
distraction so that's why we immediately
changed that policy and that's the kind
of government we are we do respond when
there are concerns and we act quickly
um viewers will have heard you not
answer the question about whether you
trust your Chancellor given the scale of
the mistake that you say he made
are you sure you don't want to see you
trust your Chancellor
I work very very closely with my child
so we're very focused on getting the
economy growing and that's what people
in Britain want we're facing difficult
Economic Times we're seeing Rising
interest rates around the world very
serious issues with Energy prices and
inflation and we've acted decisively if
you remember people were facing energy
bills of up to six thousand pounds we
put in place the energy price guarantee
the average household won't have to pay
more than around 2 500 pounds and what
we're focused on is getting on with the
job you still haven't said you trust
your Chancellor next thing all overcome
over conference here uh it says in Liz
we trust but why should viewers why
should people at home trust you to
deliver what you say you're going to do
look at your agenda benefit operating
planning regulations environmental
changes Child Care regulations your MPS
have shown they can stop you doing
things and they say that they're going
to stop those things as well how long
can you deliver your agenda now
look at what we've already delivered
we've already delivered the energy price
guarantee from the 1st of October making
sure people aren't facing these huge
Bills going into winter we've already
delivered on reduced stamp Duty helping
homeowners we've already delivered on
keeping corporation tax low so we can
bring in investment into fantastic
cities like Birmingham and we will
continue to deliver it's vitally
important that we grow the economy
that's what's going to help people get
on in life help people with those
high-wage jobs that we need to succeed
as a country and do you welcome Penny
Morton this morning making clear her
views about what should happen to
benefits rising in line with inflation
are you listening to Penny well on the
subject of benefits you know we have not
yet made that decision and of course
there will be discussions about the way
forward on commitments like benefit on
how we deal with future budgets but I'm
very clear that going into this winter
we do need to help the most vulnerable
in addition to the energy price
guarantee we've also made sure the most
vulnerable households have an extra 1200
pounds and this government will always
help people get on in life whilst making
sure the most vulnerable are protected
do you welcome the leader of the commons
making public Heavies on this matter
well as I've said no decision has been
made yet on that issue and I look
forward to having those discussions
you're facing a second massive cost of
living crisis which is the one on
mortgages people are facing a doubling
of the amount that they've got to pay
every month now now you clearly thought
because of your energy price plan that
people couldn't afford an extra thousand
pounds a year on their energy bill what
makes you think people can afford
hundreds of pounds a month on their
mortgages and can they expect help look
I understand people are worried about
the cost of living they're worried about
inflation that's why we have acted
decisively on the energy price guarantee
we're also doing what we can to help
homeowners through stamp Duty reductions
the reality is though the interest rates
are set by The Independent Bank of
England they make those decisions on the
basis of what's happening with inflation
and other factors the energy
intervention we have done is likely to
curb inflation by up to Five Points so
that has a positive effect but
ultimately what we're seeing around the
world in the wake of Putin's law in
Ukraine is interest rates rise so the
Federal Reserve for example is pushed up
interest rates so we will do you know
what we can to support people but
ultimately it is a decision for the
Independent Bank of England I mean
that's an argument about the cause of
why interest rates are going up I asked
about whether people could expect help
people's entire salary is going to be
eaten up by their mortgage next year in
many many cases 1.8 million people have
to renegotiate their fixed mortgage next
year do you understand just how scary
that is for lots of people and can you
say the government would be there to
help them I understand it's a very very
worrying time for people
thing let's remember where we were four
weeks ago people were facing energy
bills of up to six thousand pounds we've
helped with those energy bills across
the board we've helped businesses who
could face going out business through a
business energy scheme as well and we're
also reversing the increase in National
Insurance to put more money back in
people's profits so yes
these are difficult times but we will do
as a government what we can to help
people get through at the same time as
making sure we're building the positive
economy of the future because ultimately
it's economic growth that is going to
deliver the higher wages the greater
opportunities for people that are going
to enable us to succeed in the future
yesterday the energy regulator warned
that there could be blackouts over this
winter that's something you said in the
leadership campaign you would not let
happen
um are you contemplating defying your
Chancellor and buying many years of
Norwegian gas at close to current prices
in order to secure Supply
what I have said is first of all we will
move forward on our own energy security
so that's more Renewables here in the UK
it's more nuclear power here in the UK
and it's also moving forward faster with
using North Sea facilities but we are
looking at long-term energy contracts
with other countries because as well as
making sure we've got a good price
energy security is vitally important and
we never want to be in a position again
where we're dependent on authoritarian
regimes for our energy that's why we're
in the situation we are now that's why
many European countries are in a
situation we are now and that's why
we're determined that we've become more
energy independent hang on to you're
planning to spend the borrow to buy
years worth of gas increasing borrowing
increasing the deficit at almost record
high prices and you think that's a good
deal
well I've not signed any deal but what
I'm saying is what I'm saying is that
Britain's energy security is vital and
what we will be doing is always looking
for value for money of course we will
but it's important that we have that
long-term energy security and what's
happened in the past is we've ended up
being dependent on the global spot price
and we've seen the effect of that we've
seen the fact that people are facing
bills of six thousand pounds and I never
want Britain to be in that position
again you think the market to be happy
with maybe tens if or hundreds of
billions of thousands this is this is
speculation you know no no deal have
been signed but as I'm very clear about
we're completely focused on fiscal
discipline we will be bringing down the
debt as a proportion of GDP over the
medium term but making sure we've got
energy security is clearly vital for our
country in order to basically Square the
books do you think you're going to end
up raising the retirement age the
pensionable age Beyond 67. we all asking
is that we dealt with the energy prices
people are facing we've helped to curb
inflation through that intervention
we've reduced taxes to get the economy
growing we're going to be doing economic
reforms in areas like moving faster with
building projects moving faster with
transport projects to get the economy
going and that is what we need to do
because we are facing a very difficult
International situation A slowing global
economy so yes I will do what it takes
to fix those issues finally are you
enjoying being prime minister I am it's
a challenging role it's a challenging
time but what I am focused on is
delivering for the British people is it
harder than you thought
I came in with very clear expectations
that this was a tough time for our
country but I'm prepared to do what it
takes to get us through these difficult
times to get us through this difficult
winter and to come out stronger as a
country potentially thank you